Jill, as you know, the Kremlin
now says the criminal case
against prigozhin will be
dropped.
What does all this reveal about
Vladimir Putin's grasp on power
right now?
>> Well, I still think that he
is in a very weakened position
after this -- I mean, after, you
know, a rebellion, almost
getting to Moscow.
There's no question.
And he's also left with this
dilemma of what do you do with
prigozhin.
Prigozhin is a time bomb, and
they know it.
So this idea that you get him
out of Russia, you send him to
Belarus, it sounds a little
strange, but I cannot imagine
that prigozhin would continue to
be in Russia because every day
that he's there he's a potential
threat.
I mean, what prigozhin wants is
to get rid of the leadership of
the military.
Does he want Putin to go?
Not necessarily.
But he's been very critical in
effect by saying what he said,
that Putin was misled by his
military.
So it is a very confusing
situation, but I think -- I was
asking myself why would they let
lukashenko do this deal.
And I do think that if Putin
were to negotiate directly with
prigozhin, it would put them on
the same level.
Vladimir Putin could never do
that.
He gets lukashenko who owes him
a lot to do the deal.
It leaves questions.
Does Wagner disband?
Where do they go?
Do they go back to fight?
Do they exist?
What happened to the lucrative
business prigozhin had from
Wagner?
It's quite extraordinary.
>> Lots of questions unfolding
now.
General hurtling, how incredible
is it that this power struggle
between the Russian military on
the one hand and prigozhin and
his Wagner troops spiralled this
far?
>> Wolf, that is a great
question.
What's fascinating, in all
organizational militaries you
have unique personalities.
Some with a lot of ego.
As Jill mentioned, prigozhin is
not just a time bomb, but he's a
free-floating electron.
He's all over the place.
What you're talking about with
prigozhin and schoygu, neither
are professional military men.
They have not grown up in the
military.
They're play acting in this.
They have not subjugated their
forces to the security of
Russia.
They have forces that are
pledged to them.
It's phenomenal.
I was thinking as I was watching
the film, some of which you're
showing right now, the soldiers
that are walking around as part
of the Wagner group under
prigozhin's command, what the
legislation they thinking now?
What's their mission?
What's their mission set?
It certainly not to serve
Russia.
It's to serve this personality.
And the ego is off the chart.
It's narcissistic.
And truthfully, there are a lot
of losers from what occurred
over the last 24 hours.
There will be continued losers,
and I believe both Putin,
shoygu, and prigozhin are all
losers in this outcome.
>> You're an expert in this
whole area, Dimitri.
What do you think?
>> I absolutely agree.
The fact that prigozhin's
armored column was able to reach
150 miles of Moscow without the
combined forces of the Russian
minutesview of defense, forces
of the sfb and National Guard
being able to stop them is
remarkable and indicates how
weak the whole system has
become.
I mean, this is almost --
they've reached as far as hitler
did in 1941 right on the
outskirts of Moscow.
Truly remarkable, and even after
Putin had declared that these
traders have to be crushed, the
Russian military still was
unable to stop them.
>> You think he should,
prigozhin, should fear for his
life right now?
>> I think it's too early to
say.
This deal may very well hold.
In fact, the right way to think
about the Russian system in
general is for those of you who
like the "Godfather" movie, it's
as if the barcini crime family
negotiated a deal between veto
corleoni and the family.
These are mafia figures, and
sometimes in mafia gangland
shootouts, what's known in